تتقرب من روسيا تعاقب او تعاقب اكثر يبدو
ان هذا هو منطق الولايات المتحده وحلفائها
في التعامل مع كل من يتعاون مع موسكو هذه
الايام واذا تعلق الامر بالتعاون العسكري
فتلك الطعم الكبرى بعواقب وخيمه محتمله
روسيا ستكون قادره على انتاج مسيرات
ايرانيه على اراضيها العمل المقبل الاعلان
الاتهام جاء على لسان المتحدث باسم مجلس
الامن القومي في البيت الابيض جون كيربي
اسهب في التفاصيل استنادا لتقارير
استخباراتيه امريكيه قال ان روسيا تتلقى
مواد من ايران لبناء مصنع للمسيرات مضيفا
ان المنشاه قد تتمكن من العمل بطاقاتها
الكامله مطلع عامي المقبل وقد اوضحت
الحكومه الامريكيه بصوره من الاقمار
الصناعيه ان المصنع سيكون في منطقه
الاقتصاديه وتقع على نحو 900 كيلومتر شرق
موسكو حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا والطادت
العلاقات اكثر بين موسكو وطهران وزادت من
غضب الولايات المتحده التي تكرر اتهامها
لطهران بتزويد موسكو بالمسيرات كل
المعلومات والارقام المرتبطه بهذا الموضوع
مصادرها غربيه حسب التايمز البريطانيه
تملك روسيا اكثر من 2000 مسيره ايرانيه من
جيل شاهد لديها شاهد 136 وهي نسخه من
المسيرات الانتحاريه التي تستطيع التحليق
لمسافه
2500 كيلومتر وقد اتهمت كييف موسكو
بالتسلم مسيرات شاهد
229 ولكن لا يوجد اي دليل مادي على
استخدامها في الحرب الدائره من جههها ذكرت
وكاله الصحافه الفرنسيه حصول روسيا على
مسيرات مهاجر سته التي يمكن ان تحمل
اربعين كيلو جراما من المت وتصل سرعتها
الى 200 كيلومتر في الساعه كثيره خطوات
واشنط لعرقله برنامج ايران لصناعه
المسيرات واخرها بيان الخارجيه الذي جاء
فيها انه وزاره العدل والتجاره والخزانه
اصدرت نشره تحذيريه لتنبيه المجتمع الدولي
والقطاع الخاص للتهديد الذي يشكله هذا
البرنامج وقدم التوجيهات وتوصيات للمصنعين
والموزعين والمؤسسات الماليه لاخذها في
الحسبان من اجل ضمان الامتثال للضوابط
القانونيه وتجنب المساهمه دون قصد في
البرنامج الايراني للمسيره ايضا في عين
العاصفه الامريكيه وهذا الاجتماع عبر
الفيديو بين الرئيس هيئه الاركان الروسيه
ونظيره الصيني ماده اخرى للانتقادات
والاتهامات اكد فاليري جرسيموف لليودين
للناموسك وبيجين ستواصلان التوسع في
تعاونهم العسكري اللقاء كان منا لتوجيه
الدعوه لروسيا للمشاركه في تدريب عسكري
ستنظمه الصين اخر تدريب بينهما يعود الى
الثلاثاء الماضي فقط سياره دوريه جويه
عسكريه مشتركه فوق بحرين اليابان والصين
الشرقي وسط ادانات دول الجوار حليفه
واشنطن الخصمان السابقان في زمن الحرب
البارده بعث الدفء في علاقاتهما منذ عشر
سنوات وزاد الود المدروس بعد الحرب في
اوكرانيا مظالم العقوبات والسياسات
الامريكيه قد تجمع الاضداد وتعمق علاقات
تؤرق وعشنتا جدا